if you were actually dumb the audience
would see through it and you would just
never really make it to anything you're
like the Paris Hilton yes Paris Hilton
is smart she really is I'm Paris Hilton
yes you know who's dumb Bernie maid off
he's dumb all right you know guys who
get caught and go they're dumb you know
really really you think that they're
intelligent you know the woman Theos
she's dumb you know like you're in jail
for 15 than Thanos Thanos is dumb Thanos
you want to get rid of half the
population yeah that's half [__] yeah
stupid he should be like I'm going to
get rid of half ugly people yeah if Dan
said that I'll be like oh I get it do it
do it yeah imagine all the hotti still
alive right and then was like I you know
yeah let me stick my glove in your [__]
oh love it